say ilamas was on the left selamus was  on the left and they had to figure out a  way to come together and get that money  to make sure this deal gets done or  whatever it is you know what they would  do  they'd be doing zooms and calls and  conference calls to make sure everybody  came together and they'd be raising  money for each other to make sure they  got that money to make sure they own  twitter i hope the people on the other  side are also making calls and doing  whatever they can to help this man end  up owning twitter but at the same time  you know with what you're saying with  tesla the fears i don't know man i hope  he stands up and he picks picks up  twitter because somebody opposing from  the mob needs to own one of the social  media companies someone needs to do it